ghislain caron avec la circonscription
de louis saint laurent détenu par le
conservateur gérard deltell il est
plutôt critique envers le bilan libera
manger les numéros dont ils manquent le
recours la peinture qu'on l'a pas faire
de déficit par cinq ans c'est ce qu'ils
vont le rester encore plus les premières
lorraine garneau a travaillé 34 à
l'université laval
elle dénonce le côté dépensier des
libéraux avec notre argent durement
gagné
cela coule pas mal douce je te souhaite
celle de l'ivoire dépenser autant avec
l'argent que nous les gens qui peuvent
comme aux autres et perd on note sur la
gauche il faudrait que les
climatosceptiques jean guy st-pierre lui
donnera son vote au parti qui proposera
le plus de mesures pour développer les
énergies vertes
si on fait pour quelque chose au niveau
du renouvellement des ressources prat on
s'envoie envoie dans le mur avec avec la
planète
oui alors immigré du congo en 2014
michel et père de trois enfants les
allocations au fédéral pour enfants lui
rapporte en tout mais le 300 dollars par
mois
il se tournera vers le parti dont la
priorité et l'aide aux familles parce
que dans la communauté il ya de ces
personnes là par exemple y sent à l'aise
et y est cela aussi qui y ont quand même
besoin de quelque chose pour couvrir
entre programmes sociaux c'est quelque
chose d'important pauvres ou ses traits
et c'est très important
si éric lepage travail en cuisine c'est
en partie en raison de la difficulté à
trouver du personnel
selon lui le gouvernement fédéral
pourrait aider à résoudre une partie de
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre mais moi je
pense qu'on est employé c'est les
retraités qui voudraient retourner au
travail mais faut que ça valait la peine
pour eux dont des mesures fiscales
exactement et que pensent nos électeurs
du troisième lien entre québec et lévis
une promesse phare de la coalition
avenir québec
à la dernière élection provinciale ainsi
ça facilite d'une manière ou d'une autre
le déplacement de personnes
la communauté sa serre est très
important mais attendons voir qu'est ce
que ça va donner comme impact au niveau
de la communauté
on va peut-être amorcée avec certes vite
milliards de plus pour laquelle sept
personnes qui vont bénéficier du
troisième ligne et moi personnellement
je courais pas les gens par un bug je
dirais que en général les gens sont
favorables
en 2015 les libéraux avaient réussi à
s'imposer dans le centre ville de québec
en raflant deux circonscriptions
il souhaite maintenant faire d'autres
gains sans vraiment compter sur les
banlieues traditionnellement
conservatrices ici nicolas vigneault
radio canada québec